hi this is presh tawakker this math
problem went viral after it was asked to
british high school students on a
compulsory exam
there are n suites in a bag
six of the sweets are orange the rest of
the sweets are yellow hannah takes a
random sweet from the bag she eats the
sweet
hannah then takes at random another
sweet from the bag
she eats the sweet
the probability that hannah eats two
orange sweets is one third
show that n squared minus n minus 90
equals zero
many people react to this problem by
thinking it's impossible oh my gosh we
have a quadratic equation that results
from a probability problem what does
that have to do with eating sweets this
is impossible we need to get rid of this
exam let's sign a petition
can you figure out this problem
let's work through it step by step
we know that the probability that hannah
eats two orange sweets is one third
we'll write that as a statement that the
probability of two orange sweets is one
third
that means the first and second draws
are equal to one-third and that means
the probability of the first draw times
the probability of the second
conditional on the first is also equal
to one-third
now we need to figure out what the
probability of the first draw being
orange and the probability of the second
draw being orange conditional on the
first draw being orange so let's work
out the probability the first draw is
orange
this is
the number of orange sweets divided by
the total number of sweets in the bag
there are six orange sweets and there
are n sweets in the bag we don't know
what n is n is a variable but the total
number is equal to n
so we can write this that the
probability of drawing the first sweet
is orange is six divided by n
the probability that she draws another
orange sweet is a little trickier
we need to take into account she's
already removed one orange suite from
the bag
so there will be one fewer orange suite
and there will be one fewer suite in
total you can think about this like
drawing cards from a deck if you draw an
ace from the deck
what remains in the deck will have one
fewer ace and one fewer card
so we have one fewer orange sweet which
is five and we have one fewer candies in
total which means n minus one
so the conditional probability of
drawing the second sweet as orange is
five divided by n minus one
we go back to our equation that the
probability that she drew two sweets in
a row was one third
we multiply these together
then we rearrange and simplify so we get
30 divided by n squared minus n equals
one-third
then we cross multiply
so 90 is equal to n squared minus n
and then we rearrange so we have n
squared minus n minus 90 is equal to
zero
that's what the first part of the
problem wanted you to prove
and it's kind of interesting you can get
to this level without knowing how many
sweets there are in the bag
what if you didn't know all this what if
you just said all right n squared minus
n minus 90 equals zero
let's say we wanted to check our work
that this actually works so we factor
this into n minus 10 times n plus nine
equals zero
which means
n is either equal to ten or minus nine
we can't have minus nine because the
number of candies in the bag should be a
positive number
so we have n equals ten
so let's check if this actually works
out
if she draws
an orange sweet on the first draw
that'll be six over ten and then the
second draw will be five over nine
multiplying these together we do in fact
get one thirds so there are ten sweets
in the bag of which six are orange and
in those conditions hannah would draw
two orange sweets in a row one out of
every three times
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions where i
cover problems like this every single
week in a monday puzzle or sunday puzzle
you can also follow my blog on facebook
google plus and patreon you can catch me
at preshtalwalker on a bunch of social
media sites and check out my books i've
write a bunch of books about math if you
read my books about math puzzles you
would have been able to pro solve this
problem in a cinch
thanks for watching